In the world there are dozens of strange borders,
however there is one country in particular that has a large
number of them Spain To start the border easier to recognize,
areas of Portugal and France,
However,
there is also a small border of 67km.
with the micro-state of Andorra.
And it is from here where things start to get complicated
because not far from there inside there is a small Spanish
enclave located only 6km from Spain and in the north we can
find a small island that is slightly shared between both countries,
since the error border of this island changes twice a year,
But this does not end here in the south,
Spain and United Kingdom also share this small border.
And on the African side,
Spain also has borders with Morocco.
The easiest to view are those of Sauta and Melilla,
two Spanish cities surrounded by Morocco.
However,
there are also small territories under Spanish sovereignty,
one of them,
the Pe de Vélez,
a tiny rock inhabited only by Spanish soldiers who are guarding the area 24
hours a day and which in turn has a shorter border between two territories.